hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zur ersten folge von pvp
tricks
ich bin gestorben luca
es ist eine kleine serie bei der ich mir
gedacht habe dass ich dir einfach mal
machen werde weil ich so gut bin im pvp
und viele von euch schlecht sind und ich
möchte nicht dass ihr alle so schlecht
deswegen bringe ich euch ein paar tipps
bei da daumen
viele haben außerdem bemängelt dass da
hinten so penetrant immer mein schwarzer
pulli aus dem lukas shop rumhängen
deswegen werde ich jetzt mal was anderes
hemingway hack'n'slay der st jetzt hängt
er das t-shirt aus dem lukas ott nein
jetzt mal ohne witz in dieser serie soll
es darum gehen dass ich euch zeigen wie
man gut im pvp wird es versuche ich euch
wirklich gut darzustellen und wir fangen
an pv petrik 1 den ich euch heute zeigen
werde ist wie man andere leute tötet
zunächst einmal müssen wir uns dafür das
passende equipment suchen haben wir
beispielsweise schon ihren hut und eine
winchester kann man nämlich dann auch
direkt warum explodieren die haben ja
auch schon die passenden anderen sachen
sondern wir kümmern uns war
wichtig ist halt außerdem auch dass man
sich von so hackern die die mich gerade
getötet haben beispielsweise einfach
nicht beeindrucken lässt sondern einfach
weiter sein ding machen wir sind ja auch
einer schönen angehauchten black ops map
meine wir haben auch schon hier direkt
das schwert und sonst zeige ich euch
jetzt wie man leute tötet die hamburg
das wichtigste ist halt wirklich dass
man direkt am anfang gute sachen hat das
habe ich jetzt hier beispielsweise mit
dem stein schwert und ich habe eine
tolle leggings und hier oben habe ich
jetzt droht
ich hasse diese serie jetzt schon
wir fassen noch mal die sachen zusammen
schnell weglaufen am start direkt mit
kiste suchen und hoffen dass der gute
sachen drin sind werde ich jetzt auch
direkt machen denn da oben ist hier
direkt eine kiste wo ich wieder so tolle
gold anzüge habe jetzt schnell
weiterlaufen schnelligkeit ist wirklich
das a und o nie an mir nämlich jetzt die
ganz coolen sachen und die können ja
ziemlich austauschen jetzt haben die
anderen leute nämlich überhaupt keine
chance weil wenn ich einmal den turbo
einlege was nämlich bei mir dann da
schnelligkeit ist wirklich das
allerwichtigste deswegen bin ich auch
jemand der nicht immer gestoppt sondern
auch dann vollkommen ins gefecht
das problem habe ich halt wirklich oft
es wenn ich mit meinen pvp es gilt bin
natürlich bekannt in der szene wenn ich
leute verfolge das dann schon mal
passieren kann dass die einfach
weglaufen bevor ich die dann
letztendlich das war eine ganz enge
partie hier gerade hier die platten
anbringen hirsch in die schuhe und jetzt
haben wir schon direkt erschwert womit
mir direkt auf die gegner drauf und
überraschungsmoment von oben
was ebenfalls enorm wichtig ist die
kunst sich zu verstecken
man muss eins werden mit der natur so
dass man vom gegner nicht erkannt werden
ich sehe darin einen gegner da auch und
jetzt nämlich ganz langsam von hinten
anschleichen so dass er ein ich sehen
kann
douglas bin ich meinem kopf bin ich ein
held braucht nicht viele frieders ganz
wichtig da könnt ihr den gegnern
zeigen dass sie mit ihnen kooperieren
wollte wichtig sind auch gute form
die kann man zwar nicht beeinflussen
aber die sind gut hier ist
beispielsweise hier neben einer kiste wo
direkt man schwer drin ist dann vorne
ich hier wo mein eisen schwer
tatsächlich drin und hier einen auch und
schwer und inventar sortieren ist auch
ebenfalls sehr wichtig also das schwert
auf die 1 der bogen auf die zwei das
brot hier und die schuhe am besten ob
mein gott
achtsamkeit es wirklich sehr wichtig pvp
mal mutter hallo hier meldet sich grad
luca aus im schnitt ich will euch gar
nicht lange beim anschauen von videos
stellen ich wollte ich nur sagen dass
ich heute beim netzwerk poker dabei bin
das fängt um 18 uhr an das heißt wenn
ihr das video gerade seht schon in
einigen stunden das ist ein charity
poker event von studio 71 und pokerstars
de findet ein link der zu einer
beschreibung da könnt ihr mich und tran
charakter und floyd und kev und twin tvs
sind auf jeden fall sehr viele leute
dabei gespielt wird da um 4000 euro die
man allerdings nicht selbst bekommen
sondern die man spenden darf und wenn
ich gewinnen würde würde ich das an die
gemeinde courts heilsarmee in bielefeld
spenden und dazu könnt ihr noch was
gewinnen und zwar bringt jeder der
teilnimmt ein kleines mitbringsel mit
bei mir wird das mitbringsel eine mütze
aus meinem neuen shops an der am ersten
zwölf den online geht und in dieser
mütze drin wird noch ein buch von mir
sein dass die beiden sachen werde ich
euch damit hinbringen wenn ihr euch also
für poker interessiert dann könnt ihr
auf jeden fall nachher zu schauen und
jetzt geht es weiter mit
ein weiterer wichtiger tipp ist dass man
nie aufgibt nie aufgeben freunde wenn
man kisten sieht muss man die auch mein
gott jetzt
ich nenne die serie um auf pvp mit luca
da die serie jetzt liefert mit luca
heißt muss ich auch nicht mehr
irgendwelche von meinen tricks verraten
weil die kann ich jetzt alle selbst
anwenden und ihr habt keine ahnung was
und ich habe jetzt einfach mal so eine
geile coole wanted schreiben wie das die
ganzen krassen cod leute immer machen
ich habe letztes mal so ein video macht
wo ich gesagt habe ich hasse minecraft
zwar einfach
das stimmt immer noch